my name is Michaela Cole I write
television and acting television and
produced television the first script I
wrote was a play and I did that in
trauma school we're in our final year
and they do all these really big shows
these big kind of period dramas and I
felt like none of those shows were
representing me as a person and I knew
that I wouldn't really be cast in any of
those when I left school so I decided to
take myself out of one of those plays
and write my own kind of one-woman show
and that was good chewing gum dreams and
so I did that and that was my first kind
of way into writing I've been quite
lucky because I kind of had a massive
big brick of my play but it's not very
easy also you know people create parts
and you can't just decide you're going
to go and get apart you have to audition
you have to even get in the room it's
very hard to even get an audition so
that could be very hard but overall I
guess me personally the challenges are
not getting tired not burning out I work
very intensely when I write I write for
two days with zero sleep zero nap and
that can be very draining so it's kind
of about trying to stay healthy through
that I never decided I want to be a
writer very kind of unusual story I for
five years I was a really devout
Christian and the first day I converted
to very evangelical Pentecostal
Christianity I was given a Bible and the
Bible had Psalms and proverbs and that's
when I started writing poetry then went
around performing poetry and I was a
director in the audience and he said you
should try acting so I did and that was
in 2009 and so it's all just kind of
happened where do I find time to write
and then be in other people shows I
guess I've been quite lucky with my
schedule so next year I won't really do
much writing at all which is going to be
acting the whole year this year has been
very heavy on writing and acting really
you just make it work I think if you
really want to do it
you make it work
you